je vais vous parler de développement
durable et de dillon durable appliqué
dans le monde de l'entreprise
donc vous l'avez compris on parle de rse
de responsabilité sociale ou sociétale
des entreprises
et je vais vous démontrer que ce sujet
est un sujet d'innovation et de
compétitivité
lorsqu'on à préparer l'intervention avec
les équipes
en fait ils m'ont dit tu me tiens
benjamin tu as peut-être trois questions
qui pourraient te guider et aider à
structurer son discours est ce que le
sujet de la rse est un sujet de
compétitivité pour les entreprises
est ce que le sujet là de la rse est un
sujet de stratégie pour les entreprises
et puis comme on a quelques étudiants
dans l'auditoire est ce que les futurs
dirigeants d'entreprises ou les futurs
managers je crois qu'on parle de haut
vont être impliqués dans leurs gestes du
quotidien par ces sujets là mais je
prends le pari en moins de 15 minutes de
répondre à ces trois questions
bon déjà je triche un petit peu ce qui a
que deux questions pour qu'une
entreprise considère un sujet quels
qu'ils soient et entre autres le
développement durable comme une un sujet
attractif il faut qu'il soit compétitif
il faut qu'ils soient créateurs de
valeur et donc de nouveaux modèles
économiques source de dimension
lucrative
avant de commencer je voulais vous
parler très rapidement un petit peu de
mon parcours et de qui je suis ça me
paraissait important
donc vous l'avez compris je suis
consultant j'accompagne des entreprises
depuis une vingtaine d'années maintenant
ça se voit pas mais si dans leur
transformation
mais quand j'étais étudiant mais en fin
de compte je ne rêvais pas d'être
consultante qui rêve d'être consultant
franchement moi la personne qui
m'inspiraient énormément c'était ce
monsieur au bonnet rouge une à deux mais
c'est plutôt le central peut-être que
vous le connaissez j'espère que vous le
connaissez c'est le commandant cousteau
jacques yves cousteau pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils m'inspirent est il m'inspirait
énormément parce que on en a pas mal
parlé ce soir c'est quelqu'un qui
réfléchit c'est en dehors du cadre
c'est quand même le gars qui nous a dit
après la conquête de l'espace
la prochaine frontière c'est la conquête
des océans et donc il a inventé des
villes sous marine où il y avait des
scientifiques
succéder pendant des mois et des mois
pour conquérir ce nouveau monde qui
était le monde des océans profond c'est
aussi la personne qui a inventé le
détendeur j'imagine que peut être
certains d'entre vous avez la chance de
faire de la plongée sous marine
si vous faites de la plongée sous-marine
ce qui vous permet de respirer sous
l'eau
eh ben c'est jacques yves cousteau qui
l'a qui l'a créée donc cette personne là
m'a beaucoup inspiré c'était aussi le
premier visionnaire d'une certaine
écologie moderne c'est à dire que il un
petit peu vulgariser le sujet de
l'écologie vulgariser le sujet de
l'environnement parce que c'était un des
premiers à son époque a réalisé des
films sur l'écologie les films qui était
grand public donc me suis beaucoup
inspiré de lui
j'ai jamais été commandant j'ai été
lieutenant dans la marine nationale bon
il n'a pas voulu me garder mais ça a été
assez court mais je suis devenu
biologiste et plus particulièrement
biologiste marin alors j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur cette algue qui est
derrière moi une algue qui s'appelle
caulerpa taxifolia qui dans les années
90 était en train de coloniser la
méditerranée finalement c'est algues là
c'était une nouvelle donne une nouvelle
information dans un écosystème
c'était au départ un signal faible
personnes sont été rendu compte et puis
tout d'un coup puisqu'elle était
tropicale puisqu'elle s'y trouvait bien
dans cet écosystème est devenu invasive
et plus personne ne comprenait comment
vous pouvez la réguler qu'on pourrait la
limiter et si je fais un parallèle pas
si hasardeuse que ça avec le monde de
l'entreprise
vous vous rendez compte que l'entreprise
ce n'est pas à aucun moment une
organisation statique ce n'est pas un
système
une entreprise est un écosystème est une
entreprise interagit avec un certain
nombre de signaux faibles qui peuvent
parfois être des nouvelles donnes et
cette entreprise va finalement elle va
gérer des collaborateurs elle va gérer
des fournisseurs elle va interagir avec
la société civile
elle va interagir avec des ong et si
vous essayez de comprendre l'interaction
d'une
entreprise avec tous ces mondes là et
bien finalement vous êtes en train de
toucher du doigt le sujet du
développement durable alors il fallait
choisir trois exemples pour vous
démontrer ces sujets là je vais
commencer par un secteur que vous
connaissez très bien qui est le secteur
de l'industrie automobile
donc dans le secteur de l'industrie
automobile tout d'un coup j'ai le sujet
du développement durable qui débarque et
ma première réaction c'est de dire ben
tiens je suis constructeurs de véhicules
neufs journaux etc et donc je vais
construire des véhicules neufs mais qui
sont plus respectueux de l'environnement
donc j'aime être plus de matériaux
recyclés dans mes carrosserie je vais m
je vais les fabriquer avec moins
d'énergie moins de consommation d'eau et
puis je vais faire travailler mes
ingénieurs sur le coeur du véhicule le
moteur et donc je vais faire des moteurs
hybrides et des moteurs électriques ça
c'est super c'est la vision un peu du
développement durable j'ai envie de dire
1.0 bien entendu il faut le faire et
bien entendu le véhicule de demain
il doit être plus léger et plus économe
en énergie et c'est une vraie invention
par contre ce qu'on essaye de faire avec
les entreprises qu'on accompagne c'est
de leur dire oui mais ce n'est pas
d'autres données à prendre en compte
dans le temps ce sujet là je sais pas si
vous le savez mais qui par millions
d'entre vous a le permis de conduire
c'est bien ce que j'ai des étudiants
elle connaître pas mal
l'âge moyen du permis de conduire en
france est de 23 ans il ya une quinzaine
d'années on était autour de 18 19 ans
nom claque l'âge moyen j'ai permis de
conduire ne cesse d'augmenter
la statistique est hyper intéressante
c'est à votre avis à quel âge moyen on
achète un véhicule neuf
je reviens sur les constructeurs
automobiles 55 ans mais vous étiez
métiers proches c'est à 55 ans en
moyenne que les français achètent un
véhicule neuf
donc lorsque je suis constructeur
automobile j'ai quand même deux trois
questions à me poser
par rapport à ces tendances sociétales
ces tendances d'usagé ni derrière un
pictogramme qui symbolise l'autopartage
bien entendu dans le secteur automobile
mon algues
thaler mon à nouvelle donne vient
d'acteurs comme blabla car on fait du
covoiturage ma nouvelle donne mon algues
et bien d'acteurs comme driver je vais
pouvoir louer la voiture de mon voisin
qui restent toute la journée sur le
parking le voisin s'est inscrit sur
d'arrivée j'ai besoin d'un véhicule
je vais louer son véhicule et donc de
moins en moins être dans l'axé la
cession à la propriété de véhicules et
donc lorsque le constructeur automobile
se rend compte que le sujet du
développement durable finalement
bouleverse son modèle économique et que
sa réponse n'est pas uniquement sur le
véhicule qui construisaient aujourd'hui
mais peut-être un peu plus globale dans
des associations dans des partenariats
d'un joint-venture avec d'autres acteurs
d'autres start-up alors l'entreprise
comprend le sujet du développement
durable dans un autre secteur d'activité
le jeune homme fringant qui est derrière
moi et peut-être le plus éclairé des
patrons d'entreprises que je connaisse
on vous parle souvent de steve jobs qui
a fait des ruptures pour moi c'est c'est
lui le grand monsieur il s'appelle ivan
chouinard et c'est le fondateur d'une
entreprise qui s'appelle patagonia
j'espère que certains d'entre vous la
connaissent patagonia ils font des
vêtements ils font du matériel
d'escaladé alpinisme et ils vont
chouinard a été un des précurseurs des
sujets du développement durable
puisqu'il a compris qu'il voulait un
modèle entreprises différents non pas
juste parce que il était écologiste dans
l'âme c'est parce qu'il sait rendez
compte que c'était une dimension très
importante à prendre en compte dans la
stratégie de son entreprise sa nouvelle
gamme algues à lui sa nouvelle donne
c'était que ses collaborateurs
il avait d'autres centres d'intérêt que
l'entreprise c'est dingue ena qui sont
parents mais il aime amener leurs
enfants à l'école le matin et un conte
des loisirs y en a qui font du sport des
centres d'intérêts et du coup toute leur
vie ne réside pas dans la sacro-sainte
entreprises donc que peut faire ils vont
chouinard par rapport à ça soyez mais un
pointeur à l'entrée de son entreprise et
il serre les boulons en termes de
management soit il comprend que c'est
une tendance hyper importante qu'on ne
travaillent plus aujourd'hui comme on
travaillait à l'époque dans une chaîne
de production et qu' il faut valoriser
ou c'est tout c'est intelligent saint
divy individuelles qui font d'un tout
une intelligence collective
quand vous arrivez dans les locaux de
patagonia dans leur siège en californie
vous avez une grande horloge qui vous
donne les horaires des marées et en fait
vous avez les meilleurs marais pour
aller surfer il a même écrit un bouquin
qui dit let my people go surfing donc
laissé mes collaborateurs aller surfer
qui a un bouquin de management
d'entreprise et qui explique tous ces
sujets là finalement ce sont des sujets
de créativité de ses collaborateurs il
veut pas du temps de présence de
collaborateurs dans son entreprise
il veut de l'innovation pendante les
gens sont ici et donc il faut arriver à
traiter avec ses dimensions là un autre
exemple plus proche de chez nous c'est
une entreprise qui est à niort qui
s'appelle la camif est historiquement la
camif c'est des meubles que je vends à
des fonctionnaires des instituteurs des
profs
c'était un peu le coeur du modèle on a
tout optimisé un une grande partie du
mobilier été fabriqués en chine au
vietnam le call center était au maroc
tous les flux était vraiment optimisé le
plus possible mais finalement pour
reprendre un peu une une image de en
lien avec la mer l'entreprise à le
perdre et son cap petit à petit si bien
que l été à deux doigts du dépôt de
bilan et en 2008 elle était repris aussi
par un chef d'entreprise s'est assis
visionnaire un peu fou qui s'appelle
emery jacquillat et emery s'est dit mais
c'est pas possible
ma nouvelle donne mon algues à moi c'est
le fait de redonner du sens à mon
entreprise ou souvenez la rse pour lui
la rse c'était redonner du sens à mon
entreprise
ils se disent liste déclare lui-même pdg
prof de gym alors que quand vous rentrez
dans ces entreprises tous les matins
vous avez des gestes d'échauffement pour
les collaborateurs justement pour les
inciter à ouvrir un peu leur leurs
neurones leurs chakras pour qu'il soit
beaucoup plus productif et donc à fait
emery est belle dans une stratégie
long terme de relocalisation en france
de tout ce qui peut relocaliser
il ya deux ans c'était le call center
donc il a pu créer une cinquantaine
d'emplois à niort
maintenant c'est la plupart des
producteurs et les sites de production
qui rapatrie en france donc il en train
de recréer de la valeur dans son
entreprise puisque il a décidé qu'il
fallait reproduire localement reproduire
en france
il va même jusqu'au bout du sujet
puisqu'il organise un made in france de
la camif un tour de france et donc vous
pouvez aller visiter l'ensemble des
fournisseurs avec lesquels il travaille
donc lorsque vous êtes client et vous
dis tiens moi je m'inscrire à côté
d'angers
je sais que tel et tel fournisseur et
bas ils vont vous ouvrir les portes ils
vont vous expliquer comment est ce
qu'ils font les meubles que vous allez
acheter demain est donc pour lui cette
dimension c'était recréer du sens en
faisant fabriquer français attention
encore une fois je ne considère pas que
fabriqué en france est mieux que
fabriquer ailleurs c'est tout une
question de sujet on peut fabriquer
ailleurs dans des dimensions de commerce
équitable de réflexion sur les
transports etc
mais ça c'est le sujet d'un autre tedx
encore une fois alors voilà finalement
mon message ce soir c'est de vous dire
d'être attentif à cette algue lorsqu on
va vous parler de développement durable
ans qu'on va vous parler de rse ben
souvent là le gars va prendre un peu le
lanl eu de contrainte à va prendre
langue de maintien oui maintenant et
c'est nouveau nous on s'est un peu on
est bouleversé dans notre façon de
fonctionner il faut qu'on fasse
différemment et cetera
eh bien il faut l'appréhender au
contraire comme une opportunité comme
quelque chose de nouveau et c'est ici
que vous allez trouver les innovations
les innovations rupture east et donc mon
algues qui est appelé la caulerpa
taxifolia ceux qui ont suivi qui était
considéré même comme l'algue tueuse en
méditerranée et bien en 2017
elle s'est autorégulée elle en train de
décroître et encore une fois personne ne
sait pourquoi mais finalement elle a été
intégrée dans un écosystème
sauf que cet écosystème il est nouveau
et donc c'est ça qu'il faut garder à
l'esprit
et donc pour conclure certains verront
notre monde en bouleversements un monde
en crise je préfère le voir en
transition et vous tous dans cette salle
vous êtes acteur de cette transition
donc en sortant de la salle soyez
acteurs de la transition et merci à vous
[Applaudissements]